[Music]
and now I'm happy to share a new
surprise with you pissing on the legacy
of one of our most popular worlds the
super talented teams of Ubisoft
Singapore came up with something really
really unique so I want you to see that
and enjoy thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
men from all over the world sail the
treacherous trade routes of the Indian
Ocean the riches in their holes fuel
their dreams of power and fortune while
wetting the appetites of those they fear
most pirates
you
[Music]
[Applause]
120 days that's how long the average
pirate survived the lawless life on the
Seas during the Golden Age of piracy I'm
Justin faring the creative director for
skull and bones and this is your chance
to not just survive but to climb the
food chain and surpass a legend of every
pirate who ever sailed the high seas
since bring an innovative naval combat
to Assassin's Creed we at Ubisoft
Singapore has set out to bring you the
ultimate pirate experience a tactical
action game where we take that naval
combat to the next level mastering the
ocean and its wins at the helm of ships
armed to the teeth skull and bones takes
place in a shared systemic world where
you can sail solo or form a gang of
pirates with your friends and together
terrorize the trade routes of the Indian
Ocean season after season you'll
collaborate and compete with other
bloodthirsty players even execute
ruthless betrayals in order to become
the ultimate pirate kingpin now I'm
proud to share with you the loot hunt
one of skull and bones 5 vs. 5
team-based PvP modes right on right
we've just received Intel that merchant
convoys rich with treasure are sailing
just off the coast of Madagascar but
beware there are other pirates also
looking to plunder the PvP disputed
waters of the Indian Ocean
[Applause]
the Priscilla's shallows of Madagascar
located on the cusp of a bustling trade
route it is the perfect place for an
ambush here is our gang of pirates the
Raider going head-to-head with a gang of
rival players the cutthroats victory
goes to the team with the most loot at
the end of the hunt
our knowing how to sail with the wind is
a pirate's most precious skill use the
wings to increase your speed or to
position yourself for tactical advantage
in battle to reap the most rewards it is
best to split up some going inland
others keeping to the open sea
each warship has unique friends
the frigate hull is reinforced it
Arsenal equipped with numerous culverin
cannons the Brigantine is devastating up
close with a battering ram designed to
break any resistance the super war kills
from afar with its crippling long-range
mortars and precise long nine cannon
[Music]
provisions that open fire
nothing would I do now
Wow ooh doggie nothing
don't let bloodlust cloud your purpose
you're here for the loot and so are your
rivals starter ghosts and fatty aphasia
the team that escapes with the most loot
claims victory searching for more
targets on the horizon our scooper wall
spots a rival pirate ship further inland
with its heavily reinforced hull our
frigate swoops in to save the day
bearing the brunt of the damage
another day another victim
Messimer si vamos coño our gang of
pirates is now taking aim at the
Prickett and it will take team
coordination to take her down
[Music]
Deerling we can take a step with the
enemy ships broadside now vulnerable our
frigate rushes into border black and
silver back these waters of fish
pirate hunter that have been sent me
signalling the end of the hunt they
target the Pirates with the most stolen
loot captain or we are searched for news
Oh still about the pirate hunter
defenses are so strong that the only
option is escape the Brigantine is
sacrificing herself to buy time for the
frigate who carries the most loot
the frigates now needs to make it to
escape through the reefs
successful pilots know when to run with
their holes full and the wind at their
backs
[Applause]
thank you all very much I'd like to
invite you to play the lute hunt at the
Ubisoft booth at e3 and please register
for our live phases online oh and one
thing I forgot to mention the world of
skull and bones is one that evolves when
you act it reacts the girl's body
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]